يقفان على نفس الارضيه يؤمنان بذات
التوجهات تقريبا بل دعم احدهما الاخر
لكنهما ليس على وفاق الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب وحاكم فلوريدا
ليست اولويه للولايات المتحده الاولويه هي
لحمايه الحدود الجنوبيه مواجهه الصين
وتعزيز الجيش الامريكي كلمات قالها قبل
ايام
لقناه
تصريحنا اعتبرته الاول اخطاء حاكم فلوريدا
وبالمناسبه للوهله تظن انها تصريحات ترامب
الانتقاد دعمي اداره بايدن لاوكرانيا هل
تطابق التصريحات ياتي في مجال الصدفه
يرى ان دي سانتوس يسير على خطاه يتابع كل
ما يقوله هو يريد كل ما يريده من المتوقع
ان يترشح الانتخابات الرئاسه في 2024
ينافس ترامب ويريد ان يرشحه الجمهوريون
امر حذره منه ترامب سابقا بل وابدى ندمه
على دعم ديسانس في انتخابات 2018 والتي
اوصلته الى منصب حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
فلوريدا التي تفضل ترامب على حاكمها بحسب
استطلاع رايا لكليه
الحقيقه ان هذا الصراع الكلامي بين
ديسانتوس واترام يظهر يظهر مدى انقسام
الحزب الجمهوري وهو مقبل على اختيار مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسه في
2024 امر لاحظه المتابعون لتجمع تيار
المحافظين في الحزب الج في مؤتمره السنوي
قبل ايام لما يحضر نائب ترامب السابق مايك
بنس بل واحجم التابعون له عن تخصيص فقرات
لقاده اخرين اكثر اعتدالا في الحزب
لمخاطبه الحضور حضرت طبعا وخاطب الحضور
لمده تسعين دقيقه بل وحصل على تاييد بنحو
62% في استطلاع اجراه المؤتمر لكن بعض
المناويين له حضروا لقاء اخر تزامن مع
المؤتمر نادي التنميه لقاء ترعه ترعه
منظمه معنيه بشان الاقتصادي للمحافظين
ايضا وهذا اللقاء ايد خلال الانتخابات
الرئاسيه السابقه ترشيحه لكنه هذا العام
لم يدعو ترامب للقاء
رغم ان اظن ترامب ما زال يحظى بتاييد واسع
لدى قاعده الحزب الجمهوري ويتقدم على باقي
المرشحين او المرشحين المحتملين حسب معظم
استطلاعات الراي فان العديده من قاده
الحزب لا يرغبون بان يكون مرشحهم للرئاسه
هؤلاء كانوا في مرمى نيراني هجمات ترامب
خلال المؤتمر السنوي الاخير للمحافظين
الامريكيين الذي شهد حضورا قويا لمؤيديه
اخر هجمات ترامب واعنفها كانت ضد حاكم
فلوريدا الذي ينظر اليه كاخطر منافسيه حيث
اعرب عن دمه لتاييده ووصفه بانه غير مخلص
بعض الاخلاص الترامب يعني عدم ترشحي احد
اخر من الحزب وهذا ما لم يحدث بعد اعلان
نكهه لترشحها واحتمال اعلاني مايك بانس
ترشحهما جميعهم كانوا من موظفي ادارته وهو
يعتبر انه صاحب فضل عليهم هذا عدا عن
انتهاء شهر العسل منذ سنوات بينه وبين
وسائل اعلام كانت مؤيده له مثل
بالحديث عن الانقسام فهناك تيار كبير كان
يدعم ترامب وتخلى عن دعمه ما يزيد من
الشرخ داخل الحزب ماركه ترامب المميزه قد
تضررت بحسب وصف موقع بزنس
المدعي العام السابق بالبار كريستي
المقربه من ترامبو ستيفن غراشام السكرتيره
الصحفيه للبيت الابيض التي استقالت بعد
اعمال الشغب في الكابتل في 2020 وهناك
ايضا
نائب الرئيس السابق الذي وصف ما قاله
ترامب حول احداث الكابيتول بالكلمات
المتهوره ووزير الخارجيه السابق
كلاهما ربما يترشحان اصلا للرئاسه بل حتى
وسائل الاعلام صحيفه نيويورك بوست التي
انتقدها ترامب بعد ان نشرت ملفا كاملا عن
خصمه حاليا ديسانس كمرشح محتمل للرئاسه هي
الاخرى التي بالمناسبه غابت عن مؤتمر
المحافظين الذي تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل
صاحبها
يؤمن بان الشبكه ارتكبت خطا في تبنيها
سرديه ترامب بشان حدوث تزوير في سجلات
الناخبين
[موسيقى]